le premier défi ce sera le stop piétons
faudra aller dans la rue rendre un
passant sur son dos et le ramener à moi
le plus vite possible
salim et contre jaune le premier qui
revient avec quelqu'un sur son dos un
passant fait gagner un an de shopping
si vous gagnez c'est pour vous la
danseuse l'insee si vous perdez on
replace que tu te portes herring qui
gagnent un an de shopping d'accord
attention c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
en fait t'as pas du tout les pistes
jusqu'au mordovie de fait si vous faire
gagner quelque chose et on salue le
salut salut
[Applaudissements]
va falloir faire un self qu un ton
sérieux va falloir prendre le téléphone
de quelqu'un dans la rue et faire un
seul ce qu d'accord qu'une d'accord et
non pas qu'une attention va voir qu'est
ce qu'on a fait de ce qui va affronter
salim je suis je on espère tous là ce
soir
et là vous n'avez pas joué à tan tan tan
tan excuse moi bien faire passer pour
une centaine comprenant pas génial pour
nous commente une photogénie reléguant
génial elle ne vieillit pas et elle s'en
remet à des achats par les talibans je
peux faire un bon 1 500 tonnes monticule
s'il vous plaît génial ma petite voix la
fête doit être totalement quelle qu'elle
soit belle
salut ma temps délicate sur l'éducation
je voudrais même fait du bien c'est
gagner ça de veegaete
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'est d'alger swa programme gm
fatalement que big bisou convaincre une
personne du même sexe ou de lui faire de
vous faire un bisou d'accord s'allument
on va jouer pour un très beau cadeau
saline pour l'instant qu'ils savaient
pas où il est très fort ça se passe très
bien attention c'est parti
c'est parti c'est parti oh non attention
vous jouez au du même sexe hier soir
jean partie ces banques trop bien de
sauver même souffle dépêche-toi bien
même sauvé vienne sauver francs très
vite la vie de franck et belges toi j'ai
fait un bon tour à ses premières démos
il attendait la tête je n'ai pas vu le
sacre du bo fin de semaine dans les
hôpitaux nos patrons merci au plus jeune
âge de jaugeage la partie a tourné la
tête
cette opa première salle bondée
on salue
si nous alors
merci mon seul et merci mon chéri
d'amour merci